les chiffres et donc on y va je vais
tirer nettement car tu as le jeu de la
vérité c'est la vérité du jaudy vous
devez dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité toute la vérité moi j'ai déjà des
questions pour vous voulez poser déjà
moi même
vous d'où vous trouvez tout cet argent
parce qu'à un moment vous dire une chose
aurait pensé énormément d'argent je
crois être votre principal employeur
beaucoup il ya une fortune personnelle
où il ya des séries de la saison qui
partent
ils laissent des choses ou bien il ya un
souci c'est la question qui revient le
plus souvent les réseaux sociaux elle
n'est pas dedans elle est bien sûr
khallouf 78
flibustiers 81e voilà donc je vous le
dis les gens se posent des questions on
n'a pas envie de terminer ici avec la
brigade financière
demandée l'adversaire la vie les choses
alors déjà vous vient l'argent
le droit d'appeler eric woerth
d'où vient l'argent des jeunes c'est
qu'on associe les séries à l'argent ce
qui est à moi est à vous et vice versa
je commence à savoir d'où vient
alors je le dis aux téléspectateurs on a
on y associe sur une boîte en sang et
c'est vrai qu'ils travaillent
extrêmement bien allez je vais dire moi
d'où vient l'argent et où guillaume
c'est un très gros bosseur ils vont des
choses sur plein de chaînes arrivant sur
rmc story il manque surtout c'est vite
canal+ il vend sur canal+ ils vont
sceller sur quoi ont ce talent et france
télévisions alors mémoire
[Rires]
outré par l'aude
outre est outré ou tréfonds de doha
raison les chéris non non voilà donc non
mais pour éponger le plateau mais il va
donner votre activité parce que vous
n'êtes pas seulement coloriste
ses conseils vestimentaires non je lis
beaucoup de tweets en disant que je suis
fils de que je suis bi stones etc déjà
j'ai plusieurs sociétés chez pas que de
la télé bien sûr et je fais énormément
de choses moi-même serre que je fais du
montage et voix off c'est ça il fait
tout je construis mes documentaires j'ai
une équipe et lui-même c'est formidable
ça va et je fais beaucoup de choses je
travaille tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche tiens à donner raison du matin
voilà et c'est tout et je fais
énormément de choses moi-même et c'est
vrai que je crois beaucoup en guillaume
est basse et marc bellamare mal bossé
énormément on est associés sur une boîte
on sent bon voilà et qui vraiment est
jolie on est à 50/50 est vraiment merci
guillaume parce que lui travaille et moi
la gentillesse
[Rires]
et
devant la menace je laime et je vous le
dis guillaume sera jamais gagnant sera
mon succès j'en suis sûr et certain et
il le sait c'est lui qui prendra
l'access de ses beats dans quelques
années je suis sûr et j'espère qu'il
restera brassac et j'espère être son
producteur avec mercy mais c'est vrai et
benjamins avec mac os ni à 10 ans
j'étais stagiaire j'avais pas rond
j'étais dans ces cas réels et en simca
c'est vrai non j'ai déjà habité dans six
mètres carrés à
visiter ses bureaux c'est très
impressionnant c'est sur plusieurs
étages ya plein de gens qui travaillent
pour lui dire il a déplu beaubourg ou
clément
qui a pourtant le montage ça c'est très
apprécié pour tourner
il travaille jusqu'à 2 heures du matin
ce qui a de jolies mais appeler vers 1h
jeux santons n'est pas un univers de
travail autour du but then et aux nuits
alors qu
il était dans ces milieux et il est
également serveurs en beauté
à bercy en tout cas d'avoir répondu à la
question benjamin castadi moi j'ai une
question d'une question qui revient
beaucoup hein sincèrement êtes vous
content de votre opération des yeux
je suis assez vraie question je suis ton
corps êtes content parce que je suis je
suis je mens peut-on payer
non mais intel
ça lui a ouvert leurs gardes avaient
ouvert le regard non vraiment j'ai un
regarde pas bien truby bien plus
lumineux bien plus ouvert ah ouais et et
surtout je vous vois maintenant non mais
vraiment 17 content je suis très content
c'est fou qu'est ce qui vous fascine
bien les américains est ce que vous
trouvez qu'à une différence par rapport
à pas il a perdu dans cette ville et le
bas c'est un os fragiles et monstres
[Applaudissements]
il était bon avant il est bon maintenant
mais juste ça change rien pour détailler
ses terres
à mille euros when the way merci
merci benjamin et je regrette aussi bon
qu'avant qu'ils n'avaient rien à la mais
c'est quand même à cause de vous des
frais non remboursés parce que c'est
vous qui m'avait collé un complexe à me
rabâcher alors nous est rabâché en
permanence on associer
à ce
mauvais partout pendant un an non mais
vous pouvez moquer mais petit jeu
utilisé ma paupière et j'ai pris un
complexe donc j'étais par un médecin
mon patron trop que j'ai des yeux qui se
ferme de plus en plus à une manif à
excuser moi eh ben moi avec dormir alors
tout cas ça
mais ça rigolait bien des choses
salez cammas
l'autre bernard montiel il sait même pas
ce qu'il fait là vous êtes un mec qui va
bien de chercher pour l'amener en
battant
sans déconner gautier chauffeur livreur
il est là mais s'il ya une garantie
l'attend qu'une chose c'est ce bar en
thaïlande
c'est vrai
anticons quelqu'un voilà quelques années
des moeurs ce financière compliquée
gilles verdez d'ailleurs bayonne était
chaque fois qu'il vient jambes et qui
porte
non non vous croyez que c'est facile
pour moi c'est pas facile
on a on a quelqu'un qui ont souhaité un
bon anniversaire à allô oui on se risque
à la main oui oui c'est cyril hanouna
bonsoir beaupré sheridan oda
j'ai voulu participer parce que c'est
votre anniversaire et je voulais vous
souhaiter un très bon anniversaire
alors ça me fait extrêmement plaisir
alors qu'ils étaient à paris puisque les
la vraie je reconnais par bercy
soit vite et on m'appelle
ses
excuses devant larry oui on dit oui ces
gens-là ça
le
rcd fait très plaisir parce que vous
avez apporté un sang nouveau à la télé
les entreprises commencent à bâle jean
lassalle ça va très bien vous avez
insulté un truc nouveau à la télévision
par terre et je souhaite que vous
respirez jeux couverts dans mercy et
jean lassalle gens je vous invite quand
vous voulez dans l'émission ça me ferait
très plaisir de vous avoir mais je vais
venir et bravo encore et bon
anniversaire à bout et toute l'équipe
merci merci
j'adore ce mec j'adore ce
personnage
[Applaudissements]
qui viennent parce que je
sache s'il est géniale est génial et qui
chante surtout j'adore ce mec chat ça me
fait plaisir ça fait plaisir les souris
on est dans le jaudy vérité
benjamin castaldi c'est bon pour vous je
vais maintenant me rendormir
répond ah ah ah on ne t'a pas vu pendant
plus de six mois l'année dernière simon
cela cacherait-il une brouille avec
cyril ce fdp
6 mois se battent six mois c'est de moi
oui alors je suis passé ces trois danses
et des questions téléspectateurs alors
non il n'y avait pas de brouille je n'y
avait pas de bruit c'est juste que
j'avais envie de moi de me reposer d'un
côté j'ai dit deux fois non et après
vous avez vous de votre côté vous lu que
je me repose donc on s'est reposé
mutuellement c'était très bien parce que
les scores cartonnait quand il y avait
la loisne à tous à lui ce prêt ce test
est justement ils reviennent ce soir
d'ailleurs et
c'est bien vous lisez le connaisseur
des volumes sur
tous
vous passez la soirée est
alors oui donc non pas de brouille du
tout et même avant à la fin de la saison
je passais ma part été le tam-tam la
détection le soir bien sûr les sujets à
des missions regarder toutes les
émissions les mêmes tu disais même
raymond qui nous regardent qui disait
machar et hier c'est un accueil
extraordinaire acté c'est que je pars je
me suis fait un plaisir je pars pour
acheter une voiture je pars wav pour
acheter une voiture deux mois que je
fais pas l'émission j'arrive devant
celle de van gaal et je me dis tu vas
faire une connerie n'achète pas cette
voiture mais ton argent ailleurs tu vas
faire une connerie et il m'appelle et me
dit mon frère tu manques est ce que tu
es là les faut que tu reviens dans
l'émission ouais parce que tu savais que
j'allais sortir de l'argent tu m'as dit
il faut que je reviendrai la mission et
vous la vallée dans les voitures j'ai
acheté la voiture et bien je vais la
personne
n'y a pas de brouille entre nous
je veux dire je vais dire aux gens tout
de suite n'y aura pas de brouille entre
cyril et moi même si on se dit des
choses on va s'engueuler un moment donné
on se dira et ben si on doit se séparer
de ses parrains direction continue vive
la vie mais il restera pour moi quelque
chose qui m'a amené quelque chose dans
ma hadji d'extraordinaire comme plein de
gens des gens qui sont sur les chantiers
oui moi je livre les gens qui viennent
me voir dans la rue pour me dire merci
c'est bien ce que tu fais c'est ça donne
du moral ça donne la pêche ce
extraordinaire il y aura pluie pourrait
pas y avoir dans bruyante renoncé jeudi
là et raymond tu que je te dise non mais
je dis bon ça t'a fait du bien parce que
là cette année tu te régales et je le
vois je donc on fait ici je vous dis et
je le dis à chaque fois au chroniqueur
les souvenirs il semble y avoir avant
qu'on retrouve
amusez-vous qui fait ainsi vous venez
ici et que vous êtes en retard à jouer
moi je vous dis et je vous jure que
c'est vrai et vous le savez je viens
jamais en race rassurez moi même je suis
toujours c'est ma récréation de la
journée je vous jure tirer tous les
trucs chiants en fait je les fais
pendant la journée et quand je viens sur
le plateau c'est mon qui font absolument
pas cessé mais de deux heures et demi
maintenant six heures de
retraités de moi content de vous
retrouver tous les soirs les questions
suivantes jean-michel oui de quelle
chroniqueurs autour de la table as-tu le
moins de nouvelles pendant sa période
d'absence
au hasard n'ont pas la
même veine hormis nicolas mais on
attendait il l'a même pas mon numéro
donc tu pouvais pas aimé leur donner oui
mais autrement tout le monde tout le
monde a reculé nouvelle franchement tout
je regarde la paddle chine non mais
jeter on s'est créé bah oui c'est vrai
tu m'a dit j'ai pas pressés que tu
reviennes non non non mais tout le tout
le monde je pense à d'amico a permis que
la caparo numéro c'est tout alors comme
il va repartir longtemps
mais le vraiment beaucoup vraiment
vraiment bon très bon retour
civile
alors ça ça me tue or ça c'est horrible
cette question ah ouais cyril est ce que
c'est vrai que vous gagnez vos matchs de
paddle parce que vous êtes bien
accompagné et qu'en réalité vous êtes un
joueur moyen
habitat vérité c'est que c'est un
téléspectateur qui peut
dire c'est la preuve par
the game and co la paire ni koné dit la
vérité mais moi je suis témoin donc au
jour avec des gens de votre niveau et
c'est vrai que vous êtes très fort mais
trop douteux
il a été question nicolas atienza il ya
un adage qui dit grosse voix dit
anaconda ce que vous
[Rires]
eh eh bien mon entraîneur max moreau way
qui est un très grand joueur on peut le
dire top 5 français ouais je veux dire
excellent est ce qui me met jamais
frérot c'est toi le plus fort
entraîneur non pas du tout
alors qu'elle a répondu oui oui bien sûr
c'est vrai merci à tout casser à
un nom soit c'est de la merde berlin
monsieur rythme fauchon assez fort à la
mer raymond tu connaissais rien de plus
de 20 ans
quelle est la différence entre la luna
de 2001 et le hanouna de 2021 l'oseille
et pouvoir d'achat
[Rires]
non y'a vraiment c'est vrai ya pas il ya
pas beaucoup de changements il ya
vraiment pas beaucoup je trouve qu'il ya
un truc qui a changé chez toi c'est que
tu es plus rapide maintenant tu vois des
choses plus rapidement député pat est
plus patient comme avant d'opter t'es
chiant et avant mais maintenant tu
encore un peu près serré mais tu veux
les choses plus rapidement bairi lille
a10 a6 rim il veut s'attirer universal
syrie veut ça mais ça c'est quand tu
voles battu quand tu es dans le tueur
fou on dit quand tu es dans le futur
suivez les choses tout de suite ouais
c'est le seul truc qui a changé jeu
c'était bien de cyril qui dormait dans
sa voiture cyril ans marthe c'était pas
mal as aujourd'hui c'est en hélico
supply chain non non
[Rires]
caractère n'a pas changé d idée n'ont
pas changé ça c'est important mais et
mais je vous dis et raymond c'est mon
ami avec lui c'est vrai que c'est vrai
je suis pressé ouais voilà j'aurai que
tu ralentis c'est un petit peu et tu
prennent le temps de regarder ben écoute
voilà je vous vois
franchement syrie depuis quelques temps
vous vous êtes politisé vous pourriez
vous nous dire pour qui vous voteriez
aux élections présidentielles dans un
trou dans la salle quand il m'a appelé
voilà jean-mi vous avez dit que vous
partiriez en thaïlande pour être dans la
restauration ce ne serait pas pour les
thaïlandaises il faut des serveurs sous
le coup d'un resto
vous prêt pour ne pas concéder questions
d'aujourd'hui
mais c'est ça ma mère janis merde alors
merci dans mercy kelly si demain tu es
pmp s'arrête quel type de carrière qui
envisageraient afin de toujours à la
télé d'accord bien sûr j'ai confiance en
mon producteur qui hélas jamais personne
donc
moi c'est un plaisir de continuer c'est
vrai beaucoup de talent pour faire
croire aux coups bas pour faire quoi
volaille
oui moi je suis allé voir ici au hasard
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
je m'éclatais que j'ai géré il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont arrivés aussi
au hasard partir ou
non
elle va faire plein de choses je sais
que je suis l'agent d'amy gilles
faites-moi des promesses comme à tout le
monde mais je vous dis que vous allez
faire plein de choses où elle a déjà
passé les castings on va pas se mentir
mais on l'est de la côte est a réussi
pareil pari site jeu jean luc azoulay
qui m'a dit qu'elle a été excellente et
qu'elle sera prise dans les filles d'à
côté m
elles seront trois filles d'à côté et
les deux autres seront nicolas pernikoff
et gilles verdez
si vous ne commencez jamais l'année mais
vous la terminer toujours vous n'en avez
pas marre d'être la cinquième round
6 6 et j'en ai marre d'accord ils en
aient marre c'est vrai que commet jamais
l'année ouais mais l'été est difficile
avec vous oui on discute on négocie sa
marche jamais et je démarre jamais
l'année donc je vous pose la question
pourquoi est ce que je ne commence
jamais c'est putin d'année
la réponse donnée à ce qui va se passer
maintenant ça va être beaucoup plus a
commenté delphine a commencé
voilà maintenant mais gilles pas ce que
je vais vous dire je reviens de vacances
je ne suis pas eu
j'ai pas envie de me voir si je vous
adore à mais je sais pas mais parfois de
la senza vous êtes enlevé comme je suis
souvent parents de la famille tic verdez
harris très tard
j'ai pas trop rêver d'obélix arrive au
début de l'alphabet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous mairie a question pour moi et si on
médias à cyril vous êtes très proche de
nicolas de tavernot s'il vous demandait
de reprendre l'access de m6
accepteriez-vous alors nicolas serrano
c'est le patron de m6 va devenir bientôt
patron de tf1 et de m6 également à l'or
s'est jamais cachée c'est vrai que non
je suis la doré les proches leurs noces
d'or il le sait très bien voilà c'est
mon ami et je voulais vraiment beaucoup
et pour moi c'est un très très grand de
la télévision mais c'est vrai que le
groupe canal et mon groupe the curse et
ma famille
actionnaire principal le canal et ma
famille voilà donc forcément je pense
que je terminerai ma carrière dans le
groupe canal+ avec mes amis et avec ma
famille donc forcément je pense qu'il
n'y a aucune chance que j'avais fait si
on vous proposait le tri
avec ma famille qui est dans le groupe
canal à part bien sûr s'ils n'ont plus
besoin de moi qui me disent qu'il faut
que je m'en aille marca je reste
toujours je resterai toujours avec ma
famille le groupe donc je vous le dis il
n'y a pratiquement aucune chance si
j'arrive dans un autre groupe en vérité
voilà je d'ailleurs d'ailleurs toit en
toit sert erding ans oui je pense
arriver la place guillaume voudra
prendre ma place et rigolant de galles
parle de vous ah oui bah ouais non mais
je l adore nicolas willot c est le
groupe m6 je sais un groupe voilà que
non j'ai toujours été proche et sont
vraiment vraiment des amis que j'aiderai
toujours il espère aussi nous est énorme
voilà mais c'est vrai que ma famille
c'est le groupe canal+ à part si un jour
on sait jamais peut-être que le groupe
canal+ me dire on n'a plus besoin voilà
donc improbable dans le bon groupe et là
franchement ils m'auront totalement
donné que j'aurais pas de mal à le
redire c'est pas grave on je ferai autre
chose voilà en tout cas merci pour la
question mais c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup tient dans sa main est ce que
vous étiez pour le retour de matthieu
delormeau cette saison
absolument je me suis même pas posé la
question alors je tiens à dire un truc
et je vais répondre pour vous benjamin
c'est un des meilleurs camarades de tp1
n'a aucune jalousie au il n'est pas du
tout en vieux
gamin c'est un mec au contraire y penser
je jure que c'est vrai c'est ça que
j'aime chez lui il pense d'abord à
l'émission il pense d'abord à moi par ce
collectif et à chaque fois il me dit
c'est une bonne idée c'est pas une bonne
idée et benjamin je tiens à dire c'est
un très grand professionnel de la télé
et quand ils donnent une idée elle est
souvent très très bonne et il un très
beau rend très bon regard sur l'émission
sur les autres chroniqueurs et sur le
conte du club il est très bienveillant
avec ça je sais mais vraiment si on n'a
pas fait un jeu et voitures aux feux en
fait cher cela m'a évidemment mais il
faut lui rappeler aux plumes city très
très potes hébergée pendant six mois fin
mai mais il restait trois semaines il
est resté six mois mais non c'est pas si
les hommes c'est comme nicolas pernikoff
j'étais un des premiers à l'engager à
des millions sur tf1 langues de vip donc
c'est une longue histoire c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai grand personnage dans
l'émission donc allongement c'est sa
main postale pense d'abord à l'émission
voilà donc vrai que ben j'aurais échangé
cette photo de moi c'est c'est possible
la can n'est plus la même
question pour vous si vous deviez
choisir qu'une émission entre fort
boyard et tpm paix ce serait quoi très
difficile
parce qu'on peut juste lui dire des ppp
vite à mon avis non non vous prévenant
n'ont ils pas directement mais en fait
fort boyard fort boyard et m'ont tout
pris en 2013 quand je suis sortie de
miss france et c'est aussi c'est aussi
une famille c'est une émission de grand
public comme ici et puis si il ya le
direct il ya est en fait les deux on m'a
déjà posé souvent c'est le cas cela
suppose remaniée recul
mais en plus c'est la même c'est là
c'est le même groupe oui c'est le même
groupe de production oui voilà alors oui
mais bon voix courageuses pour une fois
qu est-ce qui est excite le plus sens
alors jean méhault
non
m
[Rires]
tu vas voir c'est ton anniversaire mais
bon ça va pas bien arrêtez paix qu'est
ce que
je vais faire ma dixième année de la
verrière passe partout moi non je vais
aller vers ma dixième année de fort
boyard donc j'espère aussi aller voilà
vers l'est la dixième année de cpnpc
politique si les deux sont fantastiques
franchement je vais te dire mais je
m'amuse ici non et alors ce qui est bien
comparé à fort boyard ici c'est que je
peux passer mes messages pour les
animaux pour la bienveillance pour tout
ça donc c'est vrai que j'adore
l'exercice
non mais franchement là mais oui toi